you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess
calms tactics trainer I'm gonna try
three puzzles and share my thoughts
along the way so playing is black with
this one let's see mm-hmm okay all right
I think I have the answer to this one my
first thought is that we are as black
very close to giving mate and if this
King can be forced to f1 rook to h1 will
be made and we can really try to do that
in just a couple moves so I believe I
have the solution Knight f4 with the
threat of 92 and if King f1 then that's
me in the corner now after Knight f4
there are some checks that can be thrown
in but they never really amount to
anything go check on b6 we just do like
a little zigzag and the checks run out
there is a defense in the form of let's
say after Knight f4 the rook could play
to be 2 or e 1 but still we play here
with check rook takes Knight pawn takes
and then you simply cannot stop the pawn
from promoting next I think this is it
oh my goodness that's as far as it goes
okay that's kind of rare for it to only
require one move but I think I've
explained everything that needed to be
explained there's nothing to do about 92
that's great gets thrown the checks you
zigzag your way out of it and then still
this is back on 92 with rook in the
corner
alright let's that was probably the
fastest one that I've come across let's
try puzzle to where we are playing as
white okay Wow two rooks each hmm
all right my first thought is to do what
my first thought is this checking move
yep I think I see it yeah I think I see
it I'm not quite sure what exactly drew
me to this rook d6 move the rook d6
checking move first because there's also
rook check here and here I think it's I
think what drew me to it is knowing that
we are forcing the king towards the edge
and well if he is closer to the edge
he's going to have fewer options and you
could be more direct or more forceful
with ensuing moves so rook d6 check if
King to e7 or f7 we follow up with rook
check here if there's going to be a rook
block that will fail to rook d7 and will
win a black rook and the other play
would be after rook d6 King to e7 rook
check King to be 8 I believe there would
now follow rook to e6 check King to d8
and then I think we'll have I think
maybe that'll be the end of the puzzle I
think they might blow the whistle on the
puzzle at that point because we always
have when our rook is on e6 and our rook
is on h7 and their king is on d8 we have
this rook a 7 move and there's nothing
to be done about made on H made on a 8
next let me just double check this one
rook d6 King e7 rook h7 check
roblox we're going to win a rook with
rook d7 so rook d6 King e7 rook h7 King
e8 rook e six check King d8 and then
we're up to a seven and they'll be mate
next so this is this has to be it let's
go forward with it that's correct it's
correct they might do a rip block no so
it's this rook check and then it should
be solved after this nope they're gonna
make us play it out to mate and that's
mate all right let's see if we could go
three four three last one hmm okay I got
it I got this one let me make sure I
don't slip up though okay if we could
get our Bishop to a seven it'll be mate
one thing to keep in mind is that there
is no pawn here that could promote with
check it's important detail
if these guys were somehow in a
different order in III and f2 structure
blacks threatening to promote with check
not the case here we could take the
bishop King takes in the King to a7 that
was in fact my first thought however
black promotes first we promote second
width check the King could grab then on
c6 and it's black who's the one who's
playing for a win still having this pawn
here and a more centralized King however
if we play Bishop to b6 we are
threatening a million-one so there's no
time to promote Bishop b6 if Bishop
takes Bishop King takes Bishop and
there's nothing to stop c7 mate next so
the only other try for black is after
Bishop to b6 check to move the bishop
somewhere on this diagonal no it's a
mate problem no matter what it's a
mating three no matter what huh that's
cool
I was just gonna say after Bishop to b6
if the bishop moves here we give a check
on a7 and then promote however we have
something even better if it should be
six if the bishop moves somewhere along
here we play c7 check force the bishop
back on this Square and then Bishop a7
game over that is correct and they're
not even going in that direction just
King takes and then mate next all right
let me just show you that last little
detail that I was referring to these
problems were not the the toughest that
I've encountered Bishop d6
instead of capture if the bishop just
stays on this diagonal we could force
him back with this and then give me cute
little problem right there to finish all
right feel free to share how you did
with these three and as always I hope
you got something out of it take care
bye in fact if we went with the knight
check he has much many more options if
ninety five check he has EA f8 g8 and g7
and while even he's six